la música
ahorita les digo por qué pedí que me
recibieran con música
pero al ratito
porque primero me cambiaron el nombre no
soy jorge me llamo héctor pero si
quieren soy jorge pues total me da lo
mismo
y solamente tengo una pregunta para qué
demonios siendo un sociólogo o sea para
que sutil que hace por la sociedad un
agente como un sociólogo no pues este
escribir libros desde publicar textos de
dar conferencias pues ser parte del chef
x no
pero aparte de eso com para qué sirve un
sociólogo no puede ser como un psicólogo
ya su psicólogo poste atiendo y te cura
y ya no pero un sociólogo post pues es
como un psicólogo test y cañón
de las masas no sean pinches sociólogo
tienen que actuar así cañón y luego tuvo
que aprender a vivir todo lo que pasaba
la gente la basura no más para entender
el perú no
y entonces pues este ya hice la tesis y
sacaron unos libros y a toda madre dada
la contraten en la unam y ya trabajó en
la unam y soy investigador
y de repente este pues llega a gente del
gobierno y dicen oye necesitamos un
sociólogo que se meta a ver el el rollo
de la basura y de iu de la merced y del
pan cambio la central de abasto y me
hable el director me dice oye mira tú ya
fuiste barrendero ya fuiste machetero ya
fuiste pepenador no te quieres volver
ambulante y en esas a nada no cuando de
repente el gobierno de la ciudad en 87
hace un montón de años 33 años
y dicen oye los chavos están matando
policías ahí en la ciudad de méxico y
entonces había estadísticas de chavos
muertos y policías muertos dice y el
gobierno quiere saber qué pasa
o si ha sido tantas cosas en la vida no
te quieres volver pandillero
y una de las ventajas digamos de las
ventajas de ser el último es que todas
las presentaciones que acabamos de oír
por los demás interesantes mis respetos
para todos
había muchos problemas por supuesto
porque siempre en el gobierno en las
escuelas nos hablan de los problemas el
problema la violencia pero la
delincuencia el problema del abandono el
problema de lo que quieran ustedes
tenemos a los ricos tenemos a los pobres
por lo que nosotros hicimos dijimos
vamos a poner un límite imaginario y nos
acercamos hacia ese mundo de la
exclusión la esquina falta de espacio
sub empleo desempleo moda contrahecha
deserción pobreza miseria
puros problemas pero algo que me gustó
de todos los compañeros que hablaron
antes que yo es que todos se hablaban de
posibilidades todos hablaban de
potencialidades todos hablan de
construcción de formas de entender y sus
propios problemas
y finalmente para mí
no quiere decir más que tomar un
posicionamiento para construir un
lenguaje común para encontrar una forma
de saber que los términos que vamos a
utilizar todos los entendemos todos los
comprendemos todos sabemos qué
significan
y me pidieron a ver pues métete de
pandilleros
será un chingo de gente tenemos dos
millones y medio de jóvenes pobres
miserables que aparte de todo eran
estigmatizados por los medios de
comunicación y por el gobierno y todos
eran pandilleros y vagos pues no había
mucha gente que tenía habilidades y
potencialidades y por supuesto que
también había lacras puesto
pero pues eso es frecuente
y entonces nos dedicamos a trabajar con
ellos no les hablo de todo el proceso
porque son muchos años porque son muchas
cosas porque habría mucho que decir
pero les voy a poner un pequeño vídeo
que quiero que vean y nada más me
permito contextualizar
cómo surge este vídeo es un vídeo que se
hizo en el año 2009
cuando se iban a cumplir 200 años de la
independencia y un centenario de la
revolución mexicana
y el gobierno de la ciudad decidió donde
estaba marcelo ebrard en ese momento de
regente no de jefe del gobierno
dice pues vamos a hacer una celebración
por el bicentenario de la independencia
y el centenario de la revolución y
entonces va a haber gente de marcelo
ebrad y me dice oye ve que estás
haciendo con tus chavos de circo volador
pues como de que se para la celebración
de la independencia
lg no marches
que si nos van a celebrar carnal
ya me conocen
y que es que se celebre en gana
y si no bueno es que va a ser una
celebración y si no hombre aquí no vamos
a hacerle hablar ni madre
mejor no bueno vamos a preguntarle a tu
sabes cómo lo van a celebrar le quien
mira vamos a hacer una cosa porque aquí
en los que deciden son los chavos no soy
yo
a veces viene a la gente del gobierno y
nos dice
como vamos a celebrar o que nos vamos a
celebrar
nos abrimos una convocatoria que se
llamaba bicentenario de la independencia
centenario de la revolución que
chingados celebrar
tengo para hablar en los términos de los
chavos
y entonces hicimos este un concurso de
vídeo y uno de graffiti y uno de obras
de teatro y de música y de cuantas
muchas locuras se les ocurre
y lo que les voy a pasar es un vídeo
en donde lo que vamos a ver
son los actores de nuestro grupo de
teatro el fotógrafo de nuestro grupo de
vídeo
el guionista el sonidista y todo lo que
van a ver son chavos
de circo volador que trabajan ahí con
nosotros que estudian con nosotros que
producen para nosotros y que tuvieron la
enorme ventaja de participar en esto y
que después
pues marcelo brazo tuviera que pasar en
el zócalo hogar
es el vídeo os digo así [ __ ] lo vieron
más de 300.000 personas el día de la
independencia
[Música]
pues ya se imaginarán anuncia usted
estoy acá para
si la neta este sido por los chavos
vamos a ver el vídeo y ahorita
regresamos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah
[Aplausos]
m
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bien
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no
ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno hasta la cabeza de el cura hidalgo
la hizo el taller de papel maché
esta es la isla
y si ustedes ven
aparte de que el entraron y participaron
pues pudieron exhibir lo y pudieron
mostrar sus habilidades y esas
potencialidades y yo creo que todos de
alguna forma tenemos esa posibilidad de
hacer llegar estos conocimientos y estos
espacios para que se encuentren otras
formas de educación otras formas de de
transmisión de ideas otras otras redes
otras formas de contacto y les voy a
hablar del disco
les voy a hablar del disco esta es la
portada de la música que me recibió
cuando llegué
sabes quería poner después del vídeo
porque en el vídeo lo que hoy vamos a
ver es una proyección de una cosa que se
hizo que fue exitosa que se pasó en el
zócalo que les gustó a los chavos y que
tiene muchas visiones ahí en las redes y
ha funcionado muy bien
este disco lo hicimos y publicamos
porque en el circo volador hemos
trabajado en cinco estados de la
republica
con el tema de la juventud y la
violencia
[Aplausos]
[Música]
cuando nosotros empezamos a trabajar con
esto jamás pensé que en el país iban a
suceder estas cuestiones de violencia
que hoy vivimos
[Música]
y entonces se crearon los programas de
atención a la violencia
y dentro de estas 25 ciudades una vez no
hablaron de la secretaría de gobernación
y me senté vas a ir a culiacán cas
beijing o de violencia
no me voy a las 5 en febrero y poseerán
cabellos jodidos vendedor cillo
drogadictos
y luego me voy a las quintas
a cabrón
[Aplausos]
estos son muchos
estos son muchos y entonces imagínate
que llegó a decirle soy gigante que
trabajo que la violencia se te quedan
viendo y dicen que quieres saber qué
pedo pues 20 el sábado nos vamos en el
avión al rancho garonne hijo de la chica
y dijo que les diga sabes qué estoy
ocupado
entonces tienes que meterte y ver qué
pedo y vas con los pobres y vas con los
ricos y estás en el medio del rollo del
narco y esta gobernación a ver
trabajando grupos si es un contrato
y lo único que veía yo entre los ricos y
los pobres aquí en culiacán era la
música
el contacto de la música busca la música
de banda que está chila como dicen no
está bien si la tarde
y entonces con chavos de aquí de
culiacán con el islam aguilar que era
músico y trabajaba con nosotros hay
muchos muchos chavos de aquí que
trabajaban con nosotros hicimos todo un
grupo de trabajo aquí en culiacán y dije
oye [ __ ] el agua y postores músicos y
el peso de las pinches bandas caro pues
armar un proyecto con música cara
y vamos con la música que cantan los
pobres y la música que cantan los ricos
y de algo chingón o sea no mi no me
sabes como el komander no agarraron el
metralleta de parto de la cabeza
tiene algo más chido o cabrón
y entonces nos pusimos a trabajar y
salió este disco escuadrón 523 en donde
su hermano dante
dante aguilar que es un grafitero local
de culiacán
fue el quiso la portada
y andantes lo conocí porque también
anduvimos pintando el estadio y
andábamos con el guau sábato que ahora
vive en méxico
y conocemos un montón de bandas local
que es de pelos es buenísima tienen sus
propias habilidades sus propias
potencialidades
y tienen cosas que decir y de este
delante les voy a decir cuando mataron a
javier valdez
el periodista de ríodoce
el dante fue el que pinto
la imagen de javier valdez para su libro
y es gente la gente de aquí como la
gente de muchos otros estados es gente
que tiene intención de cambio como todos
mis colegas que estuvieron antes que yo
aquí como todos los colegas que vinieron
a exponer sus trabajos
como la chava que se quemó como que
trabajó en las cárceles
hasta los del marketing a ven aquí pues
porque digo afortunadamente gano lópez
obrador si no si hubiéramos tenido esta
bronca que la vamos a tener de todas
maneras con lópez obrador por supuesto
que también me queda claro porque hay
muchas cosas que cambiar y hay muchas
cosas que decir
lo único que les diría es que si
estuviera aquí sentado en primera fila
tomás moro el que hizo el libro de la
utopía se iba para y les va a decir este
güey los está engañando porque las
utopías no existen acá pero todo lo que
hablaban mis compañeros todo lo que
estoy tratando de transmitirles yo en
este tiempo reducido que tenemos es que
si hay utopías y que estas utopías son
posibles y los invito a que tengan sus
propias utopías y que nos sumemos entre
todos a trabajar por las utopías de
todos muchísimas gracias y perdón por el
cual y después
[Aplausos]